i went on a date with a girl once she  was gorgeous way out of my league  beautiful woman but she had nothing to  say boring no personality and i kind of  checked out at one point and she goes  look i can tell you don't like me you  want to sleep with me and i was like  well yeah but that's your fault  and she was like screw you awards a  pretty face i'm like but that's all you  worked on  hours on your hair makeup outfit get a  funny knock knock joke together  i don't get these good looking people  they spend 100 time on their looks zero  on their personality you just assume  that part's amazing why wouldn't you  have to work on that too like i know i'm  not a hot guy before a date i'm writing  jokes in my hand limerick's anecdotes  i'm bringing it baby i'm tap dancing out  there yeah  yeah  like you know  yeah if a girl told me hey mark you're  funny but you're not that hot i'd be  like oh that's why i'm funny  got to fill in the gaps here you know